i was born in russia and came over when
I was very little I was six and I grew
up outside of Boston my parents first
they lived in Brighton which is where
the Russian start out and then they
gradually moved west they moved to
Brookline and then they moved to Newton
and that's where they stopped and now
some people they move out to Lincoln and
Concord where they're not very many
Russians at all but in a Newton there
are a few Russians so I'm partly from
Moscow and I'm partly from Newton and
those of those things have shaped me in
complex and confusing ways my parents
were from a particular miliar in in
Russia a particular intellectual social
me leo my mom was a literary critic and
then they came to Newton where they sort
of managed to reconstruct that with the
other Russians that were there but it
was cut off it was a world that they
were cut off from the American world
that surrounded them so the sort of
island of Russian computer programmers
and intellectuals in a prosperous
American suburb and for me that was it
was confusing because I very much wanted
to be an American I wanted to fit in
with the rest of the kids and I wanted
to engage with American life I wasn't I
didn't want to sit at home with my
parents in the russian books and
drinking tea all the time but at the
same time I I knew I could I sensed even
though I didn't acknowledge until a bit
later that my parent
world was a very rich world and I didn't
really understand it very well until I
started going back to Russia when I was
in my early 20s and and seeing the world
that they had come from and and
understanding what their place in that
world had been um that's been something
that I have been sort of working and
thinking about for a while and and and
this book is really the first time that
I've actually really started getting at
it the book is it's not about it's not
about Russian immigrants by any means
but that's kind of in the background the
problem of being a person who who has a
lot of ideas comes from a culture that's
filled with ideas and is confronted with
an american reality that is not
particularly interested in ideas at all
so my parents growing up there was just
no context for them they were these
strange people living on wood cliff road
in our little house and then when I was
going to Moscow in the 90s I found a
whole world of people just like my
parents and so you know I just put them
into a context that I could understand
for me with regard to this stuff a very
important experience was toward my tour
the end of my senior year when I was
working on my thesis I was I was a major
my major was Russia in America but I
ended up writing on TS Eliot who was
neither really even not even very
American he had spent a lot of time in
England but one of the one of the groups
of people that that Elliott meant the
most to in the states were these people
around the partisan review and I didn't
hadn't really known about these people
at all they're not or they weren't
really part of the college curriculum
and they were and I discovered these
people who basically
were first-generation immigrants from
Russia so Philip Roth of the editor of
the partisan review is actually Ivan
greenberg he was born in Russia came
when he was little Saul Bellow was born
in Petersburg and and his parents left
when he was still a baby and so these
people who had all been born around
nineteen twenty the so they were the age
of my grandparents had actually had very
similar experiences to me in a way where
they had their parents were foreigners
they didn't speak English very well and
yet they very much wanted to be part of
American intellectual life so
discovering those people and feeling
like I in fact I had a very similar
experience to those people and that they
were much more experienced that was much
more like mine than than that of my
contemporaries that of my American
Jewish contemporaries that was a very
important experience for me and that had
allowed me to I think develop a way of
writing about Russia and thinking about
Russia thinking about this place that I
had come from and that had been very
important to me and certainly to my my
reading development writing about it in
America because that's what these people
had done and they were all still very
interested in Russia and the Soviet
Union and they were they were using
these things to understand of American
life so you know so Irving how and Saul
Bellow are people who have helped me a
great deal
you